hello there reject nation how you doing
there darlings I'm Greg and I'm John we
watched the movie that everyone won't
shut up about Bohemian Rhapsody the
biopic tale about Freddie Mercury's rise
to fame his struggle with being a
closeted homosexual how that affected
his life and also the tale of Queen and
their journey to Live Aid and a whole
bunch of stuff whole bunch of songs
bunch how they created this song and
that song and this family drama
wow what a film hey before we really
review this and there will be spoilers
by the way cuz based on a true story and
everything and this is a hundred percent
accurate we wanted to say thank you to
everyone who's been following us on the
Stardust app we just passed 7.3 K
followers thank you guys so much
this shout-out is a non sponsored
shout-out but hey we're doing it because
we love using it it's a real big
extension of the real rejects but you
thirty second reaction slash reviews for
films TV shows and trailers and a lot of
times we do like micro sketches as well
I hope you guys sent down the app it's
free to download free to you so do it
now anyway enough chitchat let's talk
about Bohemian Rhapsody I want to
preface this with saying that and you
know what these preferences make no
difference
haha even I do them more for me because
I know that I'm just trying to make sure
I defuse this bomb even though it's
still gonna go off you can write the
time code underneath the comment do
something I am fully acknowledge that
movies are subjective I totally see how
this movie overall has a higher
recommendation score from critics
especially in the YouTube sphere it
seems like most people on YouTube really
love this movie there's a couple I can
think of that don't think there's still
a lot to appreciate about this film and
I don't want to review this movie going
off of what is accurate and what is in
actor as a matter of fact I waited to
look up that stuff like an hour after I
watched the movie to who to think of
because I had a lot of saw some pretty
strong opinions about the film already
and then I looked up so so I don't want
to come from that angle of what's
accurate
inaccurate overall I don't love this
movie I'm not even sure if I like it if
I'm being completely honest with you
guys I think Remy Malick does a really
good job of what he's given there's some
issues I have with the portrayal of
Freddie Mercury but in terms of what was
written for him in the performance he
gave I thought he did a fantastic job
the cinematography is really nice it's
one of the glossiest looking films I've
ever seen really like shine movie just
got don't have it sex wow they're shiny
every shot there's plenty of moments
throughout from beginning to end that
would have a moment here a moment there
that I thought was really effective and
that was usually within the chemistry
between Freddie Mercury and Mary and
also Freddie Mercury and the band John
and your thoughts say some positives
great as Elton John
yeah and Joaquin Phoenix kills it in
this movie too you know true either Cody
he's amazing Lady Gaga or Oscar yeah I
came into this movie as a relatively
uninitiated queen listener so this was a
chance for the movie to make a big
impression on me and I ultimately walked
out with a light version of how I felt
about the greatest showman where I was
like there's a lot you can pick a part
about this movie but for some reason I
still very much enjoyed watching it and
I still left feeling good and so I feel
like there's a lot of good work in this
movie I feel like the cast is really
great the music is the music so it's
going to move you regardless and I do
think that while the movie is uneven for
sure there are some really beautiful
moments I feel like this is a movie more
comprised of moments than it is an
actual film I don't know I'm kind of in
the middle about it I'm not in love with
it but I appreciate it I couldn't help
but just think that this feels like the
best looking made-for-tv film I've ever
seen in a way how's that made-for-tv
biopic I'm let you see I'm like vh1 or
back in the day with like NBC and CBS
one of my main issues with this film
came in with the pace
of the movie especially in the first
half like the first half before Mary
comes to terms with after Freddie
Mercury reveals that he's bisexual for
some reason this movie only leans and on
the gay angle but I was under the
impression he was bisexual he seems like
one of those figures who would kind of
be with anybody who yeah yeah kind of
like a David Bowie or one of those which
still at the time being bisexual is
still very much you know controversial
everything leading up to that and mome
because that's when I felt like the
movie finally it's kind of slowed down
and have seen because before that it was
a lot of scenes that were just edited
really rapidly the pacing of it was
moving so fast like going through all
the cliches of every generic biopic
you've ever seen there's an origin
moment for about anything you can
imagine yeah I mean like for me the
whole thing with the band and a looser
lead singer he just happens to stumble
on this conversation at this right time
yeah he joins the band and suddenly they
they get signed and then oh they're
recording a song and now they're touring
it's so fast that none of these moments
had this moment of inspiration to me I
didn't feel the inspiration or the magic
of what this film is definitely trying
to get you to do and the kind of duck
goes this way throughout from beginning
to end even when the film finally slows
down it still does this problem a scene
that kind of finishes and then we do a
time job it's just a time jump to like
yeah oh we're gonna get you on
television and then next thing you know
that on BBC it's 1985 I'm not even sure
what happened with that scene and like
they had an issue with air about lip
singing and now we're doing another time
jump and I thought this movie was really
gonna come to strong fruition in terms
of its pacing and editing around the
time they started developing the
Bohemian Rhapsody song the title of this
movie
arguably their most famous song do you
get to that scene where they're you know
they're they're breaking down the song
and it's a lot of fun it's moving really
fast and then the guy who Mike Meyers
plays the Ray the producer who signed
them to the label and this was the seed
that I was like the most ironic to me
ray hates Bohemian Rhapsody he's saying
it's it's too long it's what this what's
this about yah yeah yah I says it's
nonsense
and then they're talking about
not being formulaic and that how they
shouldn't be and I couldn't help but be
pulled out and go this is the most
formulaic biopic I've seen in a long
time like it's so ridiculously formulaic
so much would happen where I didn't know
for sure if it was true or not but I
kept going that's probably not how it
happened probably not sure enough when
you like go back and read stuff you're
like oh yeah yeah all these things I
thought were not like there's such big
changes in this film and my issue with
it is like I don't actually don't mind
formula and I don't mind cliche it's all
about execution and I feel like there
was a lack of breathing room they were
trying to cram too much I didn't know
specifically what tail they wanted to
tell of Freddie Mercury
they didn't well it seems like this
movie is torn between being the freddy
mercury biopic and the Queen biopic and
so I feel like if they had picked one we
might have been able to focus a little
bit more and get some more in-depth
scenes stuff going on because Freddy is
such a huge figure on his own but the
story of Queen is actually also pretty
interesting that scene where he is
pitching the record to Mike Myers I kind
of felt like this movie could have yet
taken a note from that and been like
it's about you know capturing the
excitement and the live energy of
musical theater but you know taking the
scope and opera and you know the energy
of rock and things like that I thought
if they had made the movie matched that
thesis and he's describing the album
that Bohemian Rhapsody will be on you
know if they've taken that as the thesis
for the movie I feel like this could
have been something that'll stand the
test of time and be great yeah you know
cuz right now I can see like I said I
had a good time watching this and I feel
like a lot of people are gonna really
enjoy it it's not boring the last thing
for more yes don't think it's a
well-constructed film oh and the more I
learn about especially the truth the
more it kind of inexplicable the movie
becomes to me because also you know the
band is for the most part alive and I'm
like why did you remix so many events
and stuff like that and truncate so many
things would you had the perfect
opportunity to come in and oh yeah this
is how it happened I mean it's it was so
apparent to me I put out a tweet that
was kind of talking about this it was so
apparent to me while I was watching it
like not really remembering anything I
learned about Freddie Mercury from many
months ago while I was watching it it
was so obvious there's this thing
this book screenwriter both I've talked
about before called save the cat they
have like the most formulaic most copied
structure you'll see in most mainstream
movies look it up look it up and you
will see that ik temple you'll see that
this movie 100,000%
follows this template and there's
nothing really wrong with following that
template the problem is is they try
taking all these different ideas and
story elements about Freddie Mercury
about Queen they're like how do we jam
this all into a narrative let's just use
this structure and just throw it all in
here because of that there's a there's a
lack of real energy to me and a lack of
real depth and nuance and feeling let's
go past the Bohemian Rhapsody part where
they developed the song they had this
interesting filmmaking touch that I
really liked then when it occurred work
really throw a rock the Rays window and
then the album gets released he puts on
the radio through this big thing and
then it opens up to like nothing ball
really reviews for the pretty posed on
the screen yeah as a funny moment it's
really funny it's effective and then
there's nothing to deal with that and
not the following scene not a later
scene nothing talks about that one that
was the whole point of showing those
those criticisms on screen the idea that
no they were they wanted to go for was
they critics hated it but look how the
fans respond to it look how it meets
famous yeah the misfits and everything
but the movie doesn't even go into that
territory it's just alright they're
performing again this movie has this
structure personal life personal life
flights with abandon in that fighting
with a band they create a song personal
life personal life fight with the band
in that fight with a band they create a
song you know when every song is capped
off by a cut to them performing it it
does have a routine pattern it's with
biopics I feel like you got to know what
tale you want to tell I don't even care
if you alter facts it's got to be an
entertaining movie the same writer this
wrote the darkest hour which completely
leaves out a lot of [ __ ] traits about
Willie he was way worse in real life
Winston Churchill that doesn't matter to
me because that's telling a specific
tale story deeds are the point
yeah situation Steve Jobs the one with
Michael Fassbender tells very specific
moments for a reason to have a tail
they're trying to stall
to tell it's not just a medley of
moments that are not really hitting
because this movies like do we want to
tell the creation with the songs and in
that I also have issues with it because
a lot of the times it was just watching
them come up with some song but it
doesn't really link to their personal
life and in some fashions it like when
they would try to is kind of half-assed
to me there's this really cool moment
where Freddie Mercury walks in you know
it's that moment in the biopic where
he's he's on drugs
yeah I couldn't help but think did these
riders watch the movie walk hard walk
hard is a movie about spoofing generic
biopics and this movie does like 90% of
what walk hard is making fun of acting
like some kind of punk yeah where he's
on is caught up in drugs he's not a life
changing you know he's changing the
music's when they create another one
bites the dust I love this song another
one bites the dust yes I love that song
when they're fighting and talking about
changing they start playing the bass
rich I was like all right it's cool seat
and I was into it because I'm a fan of
another one but yeah and that's the
scene where Houston they're going I bet
this didn't happen but I hope it is but
then I'm thinking about it I'm also like
does it really pertain to the movies
it's more of something that's cool to me
and not really I felt like they tried
cramming in too much with creating
certain songs like the we will rock you
song I thought was a good fit for this
movie to create that because in
exploring the elements of the unique
connection Freddie Mercury and Queen
makes with an audience and how we will
rock you enhance that connection that's
an important song to explore the
creation of but if you're not really
gonna do anything with how another one
bites the dust affected you know Queen
or anything like that
there's no need to go into it I'm just
like primarily sticking it to criticisms
here but honestly I'll watch a lot of
movies and I'll have my criticisms but
it's about what the movie leaves me with
and what this movie left me with it's
just a lot of there's no way this could
all be accurate because just so generic
it how does this generic structure
exactly like the way other generic music
biopics art and what would you do that
with Queen who is a legacy there are
their legends don't don't just turn into
some generic thing with a bunch of lip
singing and it's funny to me because you
got Dexter Fletcher stepping
- you know take over for Bryan Singer
and Dexter Fletcher is doing the Elton
John movie yeah which is just ironic to
me because that movie looks like it's
taking a very you know event attractive
yeah inventive route and I'm thinking
Freddie Mercury is one of the most
iconic immortal figures in music history
you know and to be different and you
difference in why make formula and I
feel like it should be Freddie before
Elton John who has an a biopic like that
yeah as a very sort of out there quality
to it like I said before in this review
while I enjoyed the movie that was the
one thing nagging me throughout I was
like this is a bias just a biopic yes
like here's that moment and they're
gonna name check that thing that's gonna
come back later and here's an origin
spot for that and it's all just kind of
a big series of bullet points some of
which get a nice little scene around it
but there's not enough time to get to
everything's you ultimately will feel
like you kind of read the CliffsNotes
yeah I really like the scenes with Mary
and Freddie like when he comes out to
her that was I thought a really well
done scene stuff with Freddie and his
family felt like really put in the back
burner for some reason yeah in the
living room that's it for the course of
20 years there's just like kick it in
the living room think what the dad just
crossing his arms judging his son gently
disapprove and then we don't really
spend much time with them and then
actually they learn to accept him he's
the dad for walk our kid he's like Mary
this is the disapproving dad and it
makes up with him like and walk hard
yeah that was something I don't know
what his home life was like but that was
something that I was actually hoping
would get at least a little more than it
got in the movie because when the turn
comes around it just doesn't feel like
the movie really earned I'm conflicted
on that cuz for me as a guy who does not
identify as a gay man and just watching
this movie from this perspective this
lens I was like did he really make up
with his dad on the way to Live Aid I
don't think it's like it's like this
movie I wasn't aware until afterwards
that oh he wasn't diagnosed with aids to
wait after laughs yeah that wasn't aware
of that but even not being aware
watching it's like this movie has the
approach if he gets diagnosed with AIDS
he starts to reexamine in his life so
it's trying to make reconciliation and
contrition with people whatever you know
he finds Jim Hutton and then on the way
to Live Aid and he meets up with his
family on the way to live 8 who's
chillin live repair and his sister still
lives there dad forgives him hug him
turn on the TV he you know like it was
not even talking really it was so corny
so cheesy but then it like dawned on me
like I felt bad cause it sort of like
chuckling to myself I have corny it was
a I don't know if that moment really
happened right but B before I showed up
to grab my seat I was with my girlfriend
and there were two guys next to me who
were apparently a gay couple and I
looked over I did that glance and I
noticed the guy next to me was really
was really crying at that scene so I'm
like oh well maybe for a gay guy like a
guy who's had to really struggle with
being okay with being homosexual or had
you know that maybe didn't have
accepting parents as the cult whatever
you know all the things that go in line
usually in society being gay that moment
might affect that person a whole lot
different then someone like myself per
se and oddly enough there was a gay
couple sitting next to to us when last
night as well and they seemed very into
it I want to like put all the focus in
and be like what are the gay people
think of this they say very effectually
very curious to know what the gay
community thinks of this movie yeah
because not identifying as a gay man
there were parts of this film that I was
like this seems a little insulting if
there's a point they hit my brain of are
they treating this is like when Freddie
Mercury became gay is when everything
went wrong not so much Freddie Mercury
like the villain in this movie is the
man who brought out the gay and Freddie
Mercury Paul Paul Paul the game evil man
in the bills divert Lea hate him in here
and then every time we cut back to -
Freddie Mercury you and with Paul he's
doing gay things that are upsetting the
bad yeah changing your look what the
hell Freddie you're partying doing gay
parties what the hell is like there's
one point where the guitar is Brian at a
party that Freddie's holding because
he's feeling lonely
he says he's like sometimes he could be
a prick Freddie in that moment I'm like
we're were the scenes where I Rob like
ya pretties definitely if all the two
right I don't see those moments in the
film it's one thing to explore the
struggle of being okay with being a
homosexual it's another thing where
suddenly the movies kind of portraying
it in a way of whenever you would take
time to see the gay side of Freddie
Mercury it's painted in kind of a
negative light yeah I mean it's
definitely an angsty part of the movie
and for so much of it you're spending it
with very unsavory character I feel like
it kind of clears up when he actually
starts that relationship with Jim
towards the end yeah the last 15 minutes
not much you know there's yeah much
beyond like the Paul character you spent
so much this movie going like I cannot
wait for something to happen to you who
like that was just so like so cliche
there's so many very you know cookie
cutter moments in the movie and the one
thing I'll give all of it is I thought
so many of the performances and the way
they captured it was very lively and so
at least in the moment I feel like you
can get that momentary glimmer of the
emotion the punch but I don't know how
long it's gonna stick with you you're
nothing like harping on the criticism so
much and I know that's the last thing
you should do at a movie review on
YouTube I feel very passionate about it
if you look back at all the reactions
I've done for this movie for the
trailers I just really wanted an
entertaining good movie that with some
exploration there's no moments that even
really hid and cliche Kenickie like I
like the greatest showmen I love a star
is born you know walk the line is
probably one of my favorite movies of
all time and those all have technically
a structure that we've seen before in
these biopics it's all about this
execution my only issue with tweaking
the facts my only real issue with that
if you're gonna do it how come you
couldn't make something that's more
focused how come you couldn't if you're
gonna take so much creative freedom it's
so much the Liberty with rearranging and
completely making [ __ ] up why not make
something that's way more focus then yep
- I would actually be more forgiving for
this movie if this is really accurate -
how everything went down well yeah they
wanted to tell it in the ordered
really portrayed in life and yeah it's a
lot but hey that's how it went down
I'd be exceptionally more forgiving for
it but because that's not the kitty
smoothness film where it kind of ends
with Live Aid with an amazing you know
Freddie Mercury impression of him
dancing while he's lip singing like
crazy sometimes a little singing will
pull me out there are times it's very
noticeable especially because there were
times where Ramy mouth was really
singing when he's like making up songs
and singing and then when he actually
sings and doing the lip sing and I'm
like it sounds like a different guy you
know do you feel that way like when it
ended at live 8 it kind of ends in a way
as if that was the last performance by
Freddie Moore yeah that wasn't the case
well that moment is all muddied up by
the way that they handle them the whole
aids or yeah it definitely cuz it's like
is he gonna make it to the performance
is he gonna be able to sing even yeah
and it's like I guess in real life they
were just playing shows and they've
decided to play this yeah yeah I
definitely got a sort of this was a swan
song kind of vibe from that scene and I
guess my issue with the Live Aid thing
of how I went down because I actually I
enjoyed the Live Aid sequence I think it
would have been more impactful if they
actually gave some focus as to what Live
Aid is about and why Live Aid exists and
instead of Queen doing this only for the
performance to be you know amongst the
peers and to reunite and all those
things but also the good of doing this
like the good of how this will help Live
Aid what the the purpose the mission of
Live Aid is for because cutting to the
phone calls has zero effect in the film
because I'm like all I heard was Live
Aid is about Africa you know and I'm
like yeah I know Africa has a lot of
issues specially like it's still bad but
at that point yeah can we get a scene
where a queen cares about that yeah I
don't know if Queen gave a [ __ ] about
Africa I don't know if they did but if
you're gonna make [ __ ] up make that up
make it so have your phone call see what
the Lloyds are off the hook now yeah I
mean they they really imply that it's
basically like Freddie wants to do this
because I'm left because he has AIDS
yes that was the focus and AIDS is a
problem in Africa so it's like we got to
do our part and it's sort of implied
there
okay this is like a personal mission for
you and that's just again an odd choice
because I don't get the sense that that
was the reality and so yeah it would
have been nice to see that maybe discuss
what it's about or maybe get it they got
they bothered to get a guy to play Bob
Geldof who organized it who was you know
the the frontman of the Boomtown Rats
and stuff maybe they could have had a
scene with him because they cut away to
him reacting to [ __ ] but you never
really get some moment to interact with
a band or anything like that yeah there
just could have been more intimacy to
this movie overall I think yeah oh
that's the thing about this overall is
that as again while I enjoyed my time
watching this movie I left going I would
have been very curious to see the Sacha
Baron Cohen version of this you know
because while I don't know if it would
have been as like fun or satisfying I
feel like it might have been a more
qualitative or at least a more
engrossing movie I think about Freddy at
least aside from Queen is that he's such
a figure he's such a an idea he's an
icon and so you really do kind of want
to go in and get intimate
I feel like this movie kind of captures
him in an outsider's perspective because
I've heard that he was like kind of
reserved and stuff in you know more
intimate moments and for most of the
movie he's very big very very in charge
all the time so it's to the point where
I was like how did no one pick up he was
gay yeah and I you know if he was that
way fine I wasn't there but from what
I've heard he wasn't always you know the
Freddy we saw on Statham so I feel like
yeah exploring the character that's the
thing I said earlier is sort of like
pick Freddy or maybe pick Queen don't
try to do both at the same time unless
you have a longer movie to play with or
maybe choose different stuff to focus on
yeah because I just don't feel like
anything got as much depth as it really
deserved
you know first how big he is yeah well I
wasn't bored but I was I can't help but
be frustrated by its amount of cliches
and amount of yeah I'm sure Mary really
showed up to his house and said I had a
dream that you lost your voice and then
he broke up with Paula demo like even if
you're fully pulled in I gotta imagine
there gonna be a number of times where
you're like did all these things really
haven't like it 10-minute stretch a walk
by AIDS patient and the guy said hey
yeah I want to say he joins the band
meets the love of his life all the same
night the guy quits me like all these
things happen so rapidly you're like
guys come on I'm sure at Live Aid no one
really paid any money until Queenie went
on stage then suddenly everyone over
cross the world and perform and dancing
along and bars made money yeah Oh Led
Zeppelin it's a giant frickin list if I
controlled the tomato meter I would
probably give this like a 40 percent
honestly I probably leave it or about
where it is like a 58 I'm like I'm not
thinking this is like an amazing movie
but I I had a good time all right guys
well I'm sorry if I upset you how many
people unsubscribe because I didn't get
on board with Bohemian Rhapsody but you
like a store is born okay yeah they're
the exact same right yeah if you're
pissed off I'll tell you this shot
really well there's a lot of good energy
some great performances there's good
costumes and stuff Rami Malik's great
all the guys who play the band right and
if you like the Queen soundtrack and you
want much of lip singing awesome I was
aware of it cuz you know you're gonna
look for you just know you're just like
it's gonna be Freddie Mercury's voice
but I was I was only intermittently
focused on it there were times when I
was just like all right you know on the
stage when they were like doing yeah but
it's also that's also the biggest Queen
music has ever been for me what did you
think of Bohemian Rhapsody yay you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and hoteles and
start us up I bet you want to see